المدعي العام
هو مجرد بداية
تحقيقك في المنظمة الرابحة
لوائح الاتهام [الموسيقى] ، فهذا يعني أنه شخصياً يخرج
عشرة آلاف دولار في اليوم حتى
يمتثل وأنه نظريًا يمكن أن يستمر
إلى
أجل غير مسمى ما لم يصبح الأمر في النهاية بلا
جدوى تمامًا ، لذا
سيحاول أن يعرفك تقديم المزيد من
الحجج ، على سبيل المثال ، أفترض أنه
سيستأنف ولكن في الوقت الحالي لا يوجد مكان لذلك
عليه أن يستمر في دفع هذه الأموال ، إن
مذكرات الاستدعاء [الموسيقى] ليست أوامر محكمة اختيارية لا
يمتثل الأشخاص لها كل فرد  في يوم من الأيام ،
من غير المعتاد جدًا أن يقول شخص ما
نوعًا ما ، فأنا لن
ألتزم بهذا أو استمر في الجدال
حتى بعد أن يتم الأمر
به والحكومة في هذه الحالة
سئم المدعي العام  يجب أن
يلتزم الجميع بذلك
،
فلا توجد ثغرة أمام الرؤساء السابقين
[موسيقى]
شكرًا لكم جميعًا